la serre aux papillons n'est pas très
grande mais le voyage est merveilleux
des orchidées rivalisent de motifs de
couleurs de textures
les unes sont légères comme des plumes
les autres frêche comme des forêts
tropicales ciselé lisse douce élégante
mystérieuse elle fascine le visiteur
[Musique]
sont magnifiques sont superbes
c'est plein de couleurs c'est superbe
ces amateurs venus de paris font le
plein d'image pour arrêter le temps il y
en a certaines au bout d'un mois ya plus
rien et repousseront jamais et on sait
pas pourquoi
et y en a d'autres par contre qui qui
vont pousser des années des années qui
vont repousser
et ça c'est peut-être ça aussi leur
mystère à l'entrée certains viennent
avec leur bébé
pour consulter on me dit qu'il est en
pleine forme mais il fleurit pas alors
on voit le jeu tu devais voir colonne
pour voir des sacs et du coup celui-ci
en fait c'est peut-être ça qui lui
manque un petit rempotage colombes
lecoufle l'experte digne héritière de la
maison vacherot et lecoufle 130 ans de
passion de partage quand on remporte une
orchidée le mieux c'est comme vous et
moi on est bien dans nos baskets et bat
chaque orchidées et bien dans son pot
voilà on partage pas les chaussures là
les orchidées le partage pas leur peau
et une collection de cinq mille variétés
fait nous ont jamais on apporte on
important que ça rentre on prend il ya
peut-être 100 ou 150 variétés
différentes dans la serre aux papillons
à observer certaines langues disponibles
pour ceux qui les aiment d'autres vont
pas être disponibles du tout parce qu'on
les apportera pour pouvoir les découvrir
en fait et c'est ça qui fait l'intérêt
en fait de cet événement
car après avoir rêvé pris des conseils à
quelques jours de la saint-valentin
personne ne résiste
en plein février l'orchidée parle de
soleil de chaleur de voyage le visiteur
achète c'est magique
[Musique]